I am back oh did you miss me did you I'm
sure you did thank you for joining me on
this journey being part of the daily
routine playing some South Park why can
I not spend like a normal person this
should not be this hard
oh my god just how much do I got a spin
are you kidding me
are you serious you can't look at this
spinning perfect action alright I had to
actually spin you best be quiet boy okay
you best be quiet hello hello everybody
mina-san have you have it's my birthday
today when I'm recording this at least
spoilers I'm a day ahead of you guys
happy birthday to me everyone thank you
what better day way to spend your day
than to play some self pake
okay our goal is to go back to our house
I'd forgotten okay there we go we are at
100% underleveled
but I'm not playing a hardest difficulty
anymore so I think we'll be fine
it's just I was spending so much time
and ease each fight like I think I spent
40 minutes on Sam I don't really have
that kind of time
as much as I enjoyed like they're really
difficult comment this is my house
shut up oh yeah to deal with you that
marijuana is changing you somehow
I'm not telling everyone our child
secret oh he paranoid some more in your
room what is the secret
another drink oh hey there pumpkin pie
Oh daddy's gonna go upstairs to his room
mommy's gonna go get a drink
what is wrong with my parents there's a
secret whaling to be revealed go to my
room and sleep not even supper what is
this terrible family did not make they
took my jerk
they took my really my parents gave me
the Swedish candy and I've already
finished all of it I'm so sad my
birthday is ruined God be a bat up when
we get a lot of stuffing knees I should
actually swap out some we're supposed
are we unlocked another slide okay well
then I think we're not underleveled
anymore look yeah we're almost 500 bars
Inga okay come on if we can get to 500
that would be awesome I think we can't
okay well close enough go to bed
let's go forget about the light I who
cares no you didn't you clearly didn't
[Music]
fording so much go on down and eat your
supper champ hahaha okay so probably
they are the ones making as far to our
parents are putting some medicine in our
food with side effects that gives us
real superpowers if only life would be
real oh never go see I can't help myself
oh poor young man and boy is something
in between
Scandinavian does it be sad what is that
food anyway what does that food supposed
to be why did we go to bed without
eating food as well see I called it
that's right I'm two steps ahead two
steps ahead left and right up and down
bottoms up I'm again it's another name
in staff peak this time it's real okay
get dressed and meet me out front
hurry the night awaits for that cool
alright what apparently you got to spin
it like crazy
oh I don't understand like I'm spinning
so fast I'm spinning faster
I know well like what I'm spinning like
crazy
ah we have transformed I don't like this
outfit anymore let's craft a new one
what do you say a berserker let it out
those aren't costumes we could get the
Norse helmet that would be dope
Starchild yeah there's a pretty game
it's not that there's anything wrong
with that of course okay what did we get
these are terrible you know what let's
go back to the old classic [ __ ] you
Ubisoft with you seriously all you have
to join our club to get this outfit oh
you want to join our club will Ubisoft
join our club please join our clubs
you'll get an outfit no thank you
who bisa it's at that time you know how
hard it is to look mysterious when
you're just standing around in some kids
front yard it's pretty [ __ ] hard I'm
glad you're with us new kid it's been
tough being the only one on the team
with real superpowers while all the
other kids are playing and working on
their franchise plans I'm stuck
defending the city against evil with
barely any time to work on my pitch for
a mysterion spin-off movie sometimes it
feels like a curse 70-pound wait what is
his powers because you're like me I'm
sure the power of your ass weighs heavy
on you not really and it gets released
you know
what happened that night
Gina oh yeah something happens at night
[Music]
no that's that's definitely normal hey
guys what is up once we get inside the
police station toolshed at the new kid
will set up a diversion in done wait
what the [ __ ] yeah come on guys hey
we've got to get inside to put these
days so do you [ __ ] do mine
we're here to investigate a hot lead
regarding these South Park Police doing
oh no no no this is our superhero
mission freedom pass [ __ ] you guys to us
before there's a fight fellas fellas
have we all forgotten there's a little
girl in trouble in there fastpasses rat
I suppose that just this once we should
put our petty differences aside and work
together this all right mysterion what
did the plan I think some of us should
cause a diversion make the cops head
towards it so the rest of us can sneak
in without the cops noticing good idea
current friends will go up the fire
escape and cause a diversion so freedom
pals can sneak in the front this is all
pretty coincidental did you guys just
steal our lead again innocent people are
being arrested Jewish ed yeah that's all
that matters to us should be all that
matters to you
okay one safe sleep on me stand by we
gotta wait for the diversion come take a
look at this
okay man that's strong [ __ ] you know
just coke seem a little off to you no no
this is sweet you guys want to call some
hookers what the [ __ ] is that
come on let's check it out bring the
coke tax money well spend every one
right come on the coast is clear he's
gonna let us
oh wow I didn't see that coming
me neither wait what is this photograph
ah [ __ ] ourselves
oh wow they're really strung there it is
[Applause]
there we go that should make it a little
easier let's kill him
no cell phone cameras gonna save you
this time
I like the seventies me 80s music very
nice no not more what does that mean
what does that mean
oh my god they get stronger because of
token okay we haven't used mysterious
old so let's try it out yeah Oh what the
heck
sorry what just happened
it's mysterion Kenny's became a ghost
why is he a ghost I'm so confused
what the heck was up with mr. what have
I missed there find classy that poor
innocent girl shouldn't do anything
except doing drugs and prostitution look
I know why you're here
you fed up because you think all cops do
is harass black people that's what you
send us out to do I know that to a young
kid it can seem like cops are racist and
bigoted but you can't believe what the
media tells you cops are just people
like you your friends your family people
who work hard get over yourself token he
shot at tweek come on but those cops
need a main observation room maybe we
can find some guns soft room oh wow this
place makes me feel very uncomfortable
tokens in here let's go oh my bad
what in the world is happening there we
go that looks like an override switch
well it must be impossible even my
temperatures can't take on something
like that oh it's a pause spell they
left these
here we go everybody we got four seconds
three seconds to say oh my god there we
go I did it must be some kind of genius
we can just go here Hey look at that
everybody we did it
hey this time we need hamster he's so
cute
stop forgot that that was what happens
works every time do we have to go down
all the way okay yeah I'm coming just
give me one moment please think oh I
missed a boxer who cares when you
bothered by this does this bother you
well that's too bad okay I can't do
anything everything what should I get
zero tolerance just like I got zero
definite plate oh hey you're the one who
got me put in here what yes you're on
the wrong side of history young whatever
you are it wasn't me I swear
[Music]
oh my god Oh No
well it looks like we got it beat up
some racist caps are they all targeting
token that would be hilarious poor token
[Music]
they don't know always attack your token
whatever listen I thought it would be a
good meme but clearly it wasn't about
game Hey got them all when we shot scare
PewDiePie season 2 one of the one of the
scenes was in a prison like this and I
almost liked those gates things they
open all together and I had my hand in
the cell like as a meme while they open
it and my hand got stuck and it was just
about to like squeeze it to the point
where I would at legit just break my
hand
luckily they stopped it like right in
time but it was pretty [ __ ] close man
kind of thing you will never see but
what can you do
alright we're done here clean up boys I
haven't seen what mysterion does when
he's a ghost but we'll save it for
another time I suppose a rat a rat Iraq
another battle defeated ok ok I know
this looks bad
you really think cops just go around
arresting black people for no reason
purpose could that possibly serve it's
reverse discrimination that's what it is
if we were all black cops and our jails
were filled with white people nobody
would say a word so I guess you've
learned that the real bigots here are
you
kids guess you can all go home no [ __ ]
well I guess we loot this guy sorry for
being bigoted that's open we're innocent
so breaking out of jail isn't a crime
right I'm not sticking around to find
out I smelled a class-action lawsuit
supreme court here we come token what
did I tell you about playing too rough
mom I was defending justice I don't care
what you were defending you could have
gotten hurt
I could wear khaki he's impervious to
pain is he impervious to getting his
butt spanked no that's right
depends still spank their kids but what
the heck that's not very Christian no
like that all right let's get that cop
Overlord guy thingy are they just like
tokens anyway they just let token
continued nay we can blow this up I
don't know why I did that maybe I can
move the propane tank
well well well I could move the propane
tank I must be some sort of genius I
know that's what you're thinking right
how does it solve the puzzle
with such elegance and eloquence and
other words I know it's my Swiss chin
I can't happen it's comes naturally like
the parts of but Lord we got a pristine
costume how about that okay so it's
stuck man I am really dumb anyway yeah
me neither
oh my god it's one of those spam things
of course I can use [ __ ] oh I can use
Kyle here come on wait oops sorry about
that wasn't focused cash man's [ __ ] is
a big fat [ __ ]
nothing like some good parkour okay now
we can do the power switch got it
hamster go I don't know what I think
about this whole buddy
thing
usually usually they they put them in
games as a way to like go through areas
that you couldn't go through before but
it just seems like a way to prolong the
gameplay I'm sure there's some stuff
back yeah anyway we did it now how do we
get down there okay I guess we got a
jump hardcore down again okay okay well
glad we did that
tokens already left excellent maybe the
cop got him Edgar's glue what the heck
is what is he doing
ill yeah he'll stop all right can't
stand here no really it is charged okay
okay
disgusting this game is disgusting
despicable but I love it
Wow Wow that's what we did we move the
monitor everyone with a fart I suppose
we have to do the same over here no oh
my god
[Music]
bye master puzzle solver everyone that's
me know what a cop is new kid huh
a cop is a slave a robot was told not to
think for himself it's the politicians
who are the real bigots that mayor has
been sitting in her office telling us we
have to change our ways the only way to
have her removed was to raise crime in
the streets and now cops are finally
able to do things the old way again
don't you see this is better for
everyone we found him freedom fells
we've got the police sheet top floor
what can I say you kids have me by the
balls
almost by the balls all the most you
know not every prisoner we have here is
black we actually do have one white guy
oh my god who is it
oh my god this is a trap
I'm sorry kids but you left me no choice
and Terry oh it's a sandwich subway
hey kids you want some candy oh [ __ ]
it's Jared you'll excuse me if I don't
want to watch this so Jared was like for
those who don't know you probably know
he was his face for Subway because he
lost a lot of weight
supposedly eating Subway's yourself and
then he turned out to be a pedophile
I can't attack anything but him here
this sucks
he'll oh oh my god make way for
mysterion
can you see really no one can attack
because he has that thing they
[Music]
what is he gonna do i'm reaiiy legit
scared that's a microaggression what do
you mean what do you mean I need to eat
oh my god here there's a lot of that oh
that's disgusting I'm gonna rewind all
right what do we got no no don't hey
Lynn
we'll handle these kids for you he's
giving us candy what a waste
have something sweet what in the world
wow he does a lot of damage
stop oh my god just don't heal him just
oh wait he comes back just don't here
yeah all right nice ooh almost in your
level what close main we're close new
kid partners face that's there's more
cells down below cops take that elevator
prisoners go down there but they don't
come back
what's the code come on how should I
know huh yeah I see them type it in 1 4
7 7 please I'm sorry it's just that I
like being with children you know
because because I never had a childhood
of my own yeah that's it I like kids cuz
I never had a childhood it's your
decision new kid
being a superhero is deciding what to do
it moments like these oh we're
definitely gonna fart in his face
as easy check wasn't that hard car I
expected more of a buildup alright well
that was pretty uncomfortable I know
being a vector for disease it's kind of
my thing but I I feel kind of dirty
should we do anything what is he dead
yeah okay let's find cheap Casey oh wait
what's over here that's something you
don't see every day
a Ford execution well okay if you're
pointing to kill Murphy cami this must
be him no oh yeah there was the pass
code one four seven seven what did she
say one four seven seven four takes
serve bang bang this is a one-time shot
[ __ ] after tonight we are enemies again
our petty little differences aren't what
matter right now mysterion black lives
matter
yeah dick you're a [ __ ] dick mosquito
let's go open the gate
what in the world is happening here it's
a code well things got real spooky
caring for your elder God here Hey look
at my new outfit pretty dope huh okay
let's go to anymore oh no oh no this is
not good
PewDiePie is gonna come out as the
villain of it all oh we can drag this
one don't know what I just grabbed but
you know come on there must be something
else here are you serious
why not we go forensic first what was
that what is this hello hello someone
there no I guess no one's there or else
they would have said something yes just
me and you kitty oh no no one's gonna
find us in here come on give me that
good stuff nanus the cat got away no we
needed stupid cat hang in here it sounds
like the cat's getting into the toxic
chemicals darn it that's not good
I hope those weren't the toxic chemicals
I was just talking about that broke on
the flow just now oh no I think they
were drat those chemicals mixed together
on the floor it'll turn into a gas that
will kill me in seconds blast it there's
the gas yes it's definitely killing me
now
[Music]
well thank God now where's that I think
the into the killing me again yeah
I'm we can't do anything by the way
yeah thank you for turning on the light
appreciate it
can we save his lap yes perhaps there's
still chance I wasn't me I swear
now shove the thing up my butt
thank you thank you very much and here
we go what is that a chicken in the fan
oh it's oh no he's stuck we got to save
him
what is that random hand uh we need
something la chemise Long's time farts
thank God we had time farts what would I
possibly do without it there it is okay
now we get there half the gas actually
we might need to
fight fire with fire or fourths with
parts as one would say oh is that don't
tell me the cat is dead not after all of
this
please sparkles no I can't touch him
anyway or is that something else
wait what no there's no that's another
cat is there something here oh yeah we
never see these but it's for Captain
diabetes I forgot I forgot about his
power this is the weird one man I mean
they're all weak thank you
we got the skeleton key everyone oh okay
that means we can keep going and then
we've been in the morgue yeah okay
skeleton Tequila there's all police
officers have one of these it must be a
standard building isn't it
oh these awkward moments in the loading
screen haven't you missed them it's just
great wait what do they say that it's
not questions your faithful servants the
Destroyers of light yeah yeah shut [ __ ]
Rev Black Goat of 1000 morbid young draw
down the moon and distinguish the Sun
all right now I rap put him in the ho
about oh it is an action oh I see I
guess because cops feed
african-americans to an elder god
they're racist some [ __ ] off is an
outer God kids who must be a piece and
whose coming was foretold by the great
HP Lovecraft
but I suppose HP Lovecraft was a race as
you oh [ __ ]
was he really like like I didn't know
that
let's end it all right you kids want a
battle let's do this
here it comes defeat chub neighborette
okay Chuck another one in
no not kz o shove neighbor and oh wow
that is that is quite something yes star
token you will be we need to push them
into their into the neighbor ranch I
don't know which one of us have knocked
back spells or did we just kill them
[Applause]
The Heretic has cursed me
[Music]
let's end our round here I'm not your
worst nightmare I aspire to be and there
hopefully this is not crack it doesn't
no point as if your life wasn't already
spinning out of control
No
well you bring harm to the goat with a
thousand young I'm here to protect the
night queen why does he keep sniffing
the cat did I hey Johnson there's a
tricky one in it okay I get it I get I
just got to keep feeding it to him
doesn't matter if I kill longer so we
just got to do one more and we should be
all clear here we are finally that was I
don't have any knock back spells I only
have one with my character so that was a
lot harder than it needs to be but hey
we did it everyone and the spirit of
Christmas mostly hey we unlocked another
spot it's about a heck yeah man
that's what I'm talking about
damn leveling up Dan Master look at that
finally she said neighbor
[Music]
wait what's going on
where are you taking that cat trophy
earned an end to racism certain Intel we
have that we can't share with you you
know it's that's bad that's because
we've been tricked
ah the new kid played us Freedom House
wanting to join our side was a real oh
my god
what yeah the new kid kind of totally
[ __ ] you guys over sorry to the police
station and now intend to get a hundred
dollar reward for that missing cat well
all's fair in love and war freedom you
[ __ ]
we're the ones that stopped the police
chief's evil plan we deserve that
hundred dollar reward oh yeah just try
to take it from us we will Civil War
three it's going down that's it you'll
kiss we're gonna rip you apart
no mysterion we won't fight the new kid
they will oh my he's using mind-bending
attacks
what is happening here sorry chaos
unfortunately dr. Timothy can only
dominate so many mites at once oh that
makes sense so I guess this is another
one we have to get Timmy Wow here's a
ship by God
what do I well these go down pretty
quick did I just say quiet instead of
wait well done me thank you very much oh
okay let's drink one of these then okay
we only have Kyle left okay everyone is
everyone is out everyone's on us thank
you thank you very much it's gonna be
more now captain diabetes make up the
old-fashioned way what is that special
the objective defeat dr. Timothy we're
gonna do it easy oh my god he's gonna do
a lot of damage in you know be mind
controls I hate it so annoying you know
I'm gonna block that one just cuz I need
I need everyone on my side yeah turn
denied you're gonna heal
oh no what happened
I think the game froze and I literally
was just about to beat no come on dude
are you kidding me this took so long oh
[Music]
no oh my god finally just kind of
annoying
Howard fleshed out but okay we did it
what well what what happened how'd my
lip get busted where the [ __ ] did classy
go dr. Timothy yeah where's classy to be
honest he was trying to help us
understand dr. Timothy was working on a
way to save all of us
freedom pals and [ __ ] friends what oh my
god
Oh easy doc you've taken a lot of hits
Wow this is your guy face this is dick
this looks like so much fun
yeah he's cool air has not closed that
soon but that is care dr. Timothy was
never your enemy he was trying to help
us all
but how with this
oh my god he had a plan for the
franchise it was doctor Timothy's
passion he worked tirelessly on it a
franchise plan to involve everyone each
hero got their own movie and TV series
every hero mathematically equal to the
other so while we were out trying to
stick it to you guys timmy was actually
trying to include us yeah and then this
kid nearly killed him we're sorry the
new kid is an [ __ ] that isn't our
fault yeah we were just using you guys
who's paying hundred bucks for that cat
we are the best when we're all together
it's too late for that
meals started as one team we all wanted
to be superheroes for the same reason to
sell our franchise and make millions of
dollars let's be one team again I agree
come on guys no more Civil War let's get
the reward money for this cat and you've
been together for one franchise Nick
let's do it but we're calling it freedom
house freedom pals oh my god a Cartman
is me Jimmy sort of the leader of
freedom path he's like don't he's like
the one in charge yes well I think it's
awesome
honestly freedom houses are way better
name than [ __ ] in France freedom freedom
pass I'm super cool with this then
itself tomorrow we get the reward money
for scrambles and we use it to
kick-start Timmy's franchise plan
together Freedom House retribution
inclusion [ __ ] yeah you guys let's do
this
oh my god
[Music]
but it wasn't that simple was it what do
we got here well I'm gonna have to end
this episode here this has been going on
quite a while thank you guys for
watching I hope you enjoyed as always
really appreciate it and I'll see you
next time I'm gonna enjoy my breath to
neck goodbye squirt there